let's talk about why Palestinians in
East Jerusalem are losing their
[Applause]
homes Jerusalem is a place unlike
anywhere else in the world an ancient
city that's considered holy in Islam
Judaism and
Christianity it's also home to Israelis
and Palestinians who both claim the city
as their Capital although Jerusalem's
status has never been settled nor has
the issue of a Palestinian State you
have both Israelis and Palestinians that
live within the a shared City but that
city is not necessarily shared to the
fullest extent East Jerusalem is the S
side of the city that's considered
Palestinian territory under
international law but it's under Israeli
military occupation and for years we've
been seeing things like
this Palestinian families being evicted
from their
homes their houses are getting BN
down at the same time Israeli
settlements are expanding with every
eviction every demolition the space for
Palestinians in East Jerusalem is
steadily shrinking the Israeli
government has often said these are just
real estate disputes but when you speak
to the people involved it's clearly so
much more than
[Music]
that
the Arabs that they say this is
Palestine they lie the Bible says this
land belong to the Jewish people there
are so many layers to what's going on so
we've come to East Jerusalem to help you
get a sense of what's actually happening
and
why
[Music]
nura gate sublaban is taking us to the
apartment where she was born and had
lived her whole life until she was
evicted in July
2023 she fought a long legal battle that
went all the way to the Israeli Supreme
Court
eviction cases like noras are mostly
being driven by Israeli settler
organizations these are well-funded
groups that promote Jewish settlement in
Palestinian
neighborhoods in nura's case a settler
group obtained ownership of the proper
and then built a case to kick Noah out
even though she had what's called
protected tency we'll explain that
later to understand what's going on in
case's like noras we need to take things
back to
1948 after Israel proclaimed itself a
state on land that had previously been
Palestine under British
control five Arab countries went to war
with Israel and there was a massive
displacement of people including more
than 700,000 Palestinians who fled or
were forced from their
homes this was also a period when
hundreds hundreds of thousands of Jews
were being expelled from Arab
countries the war ended with a set of
agreements that divided the land between
Israel and Arab controlled territories
separated by what's called The Green
Line Jordan controlled the West
Bank Egypt controlled Gaza and Jerusalem
was split in two Israel controlled West
Jerusalem Jordan controlled East
Jerusalem which includes the old city a
waloff area where the main Rel religious
sites are in 1967 there was another war
and Israel seized and occupied more land
including East Jerusalem and the West
Bank but the 1949 green line still
represents the internationally
recognized borders of Israel so
technically the green line runs through
here dividing West Jerusalem and East
Jerusalem but in practice you can see
there's no actual separation here and
Israel applies its own set of laws on
both sides even though according to
inter international law East Jerusalem
is Palestinian territory under
occupation so it's not considered
sovereign Israeli
territory and under international law
the occupier is supposed to stick to
certain
rules thank
you an occupying power is not allowed to
apply its own legal system in the
occupied territory un occupying power is
not allowed to transfer civilian
populations from their homes or to
deport them Israel still continues to do
that the wrong law is being applied and
the wrong courts are being applied and
it's through the Israeli court system
that evictions are being enforced in
East
Jerusalem since 1970 it's estimated that
more than 160 families have been evicted
right now another 200 families around a
thousand people are at risk the eviction
process usually starts with settler
groups obtaining ownership of a property
where Palestinians live and there's one
Israeli law that's really important here
the legal and administrative matters law
and essentially what it does is it
affords land restitution rights to Jews
who allegedly owned properties in East
Jerusalem prior to 1948 what does that
mean it essentially grants them the
right to reclaim assets that they lost
in the 1948 War now it is extremely
discriminatory because there is no
parallel legal mechanism for
Palestinians who lost properties in the
same War so if we go back to Norah's
case an Israeli settler group was able
to claim ownership of the apartment
based on that law but Norah still had a
right to live there because she had that
protected tency we mentioned earlier
it's a type of long-term lease that
Jordan granted to Palestinian refugees
while it was in charge of East
Jerusalem after Israel took over in
1967 Palestinians like Norah's family
were allowed to keep those leases but
under strict conditions once settlers
got the rights to no's apartment they
spent decades trying to convince the
Israeli courts that she'd broken those
tency conditions and they finally
managed to evict her in
2023 what we've seen is that over the
years you have settler organizations or
groups that have exploited and continue
to exploit this 1970 law to acquire the
rights or alleged rights to these
properties and remove the protected
tency from the Palestinian family they
are radical settler groups that have a
particular aim and goal which is to
judaize or Israel eyesee Jerusalem it's
not just these Fringe settler groups
that are working individually and
working by themselves they are aided and
embedded by the state on all levels the
Ministries the municipality and laws and
courts are all instrumentalized in order
to displace Palestinians as much as
possible and H increase the number the
Jewish population in Jerusalem this is a
stated goal for Israel they are not shy
about it especially in recent years as
Israel's government has become
increasingly right-wing and pro-settler
politicians have been given senior
positions people like itamar benir who
became national security minister in
2022 he's a settler himself a member of
the parliament and leader of a far-right
party called Jewish
power before he became a minister benir
often came to the neighborhood of sh
Shar to show his support for settlers he
even set up a makeshift office right
outside this house where the solemn
family
live
recently a settler activist bought the
rights to the solemn family's house and
is trying to revive an eviction order
from the 1980s that was never
enforced and while Fatima and her family
are fighting to stay in their home they
also face harassment from
settlers
[Music]
fore
[Applause]
[Music]
most weeks there are rival protests in
Shar between Palestinians and activists
who support their cause and
settlers
Fatima is one of the
regulars so is the settler trying to
evict her yonatan ysf who's a member of
the Jerusalem city
council your house it's my house I
because I buy from the people that they
have documents that the this house
belong to them I buy it and I have laws
and according to the law this is my
house I'm here because the Bible says
this area all the land of Israel
belonged to the Jewish people but today
Jerusalem is important to Muslims to
Christians to so many millions of people
very important but it's belong to the
Jewish so you've got settler groups
pursuing evictions of Palestinians
through Israeli courts that's one
pattern playing
out another is the way Palestinians are
getting squeezed out of East Jerusalem
through restrictions on construction and
the demolition of homes that the Israeli
authorities classify as
illegal it comes down to the rules that
Israel imposed after
1967 about how land is allocated and who
can build what and where only 13% was
zoned for Palestinian construction and
residential development but those areas
were already built up so there's no real
space for new houses and building
anything like an extension for a growing
family requires a permit from the
Jerusalem
municipality the process can take years
it's expensive and applications are very
often rejected so many Palestinians
build anyway without
permits at least a third of Palestinian
homes in East Jerusalem don't have the
right permits and are therefore
considered illegal by Israel which puts
all those Homes at risk of demolition
Arya King is a prominent settler
activist who's now a deputy mayor of of
Jerusalem Arab are not above the law
Arabs if they want to build legally they
can build legally so one thing is having
the option to build another thing is
being granted the building permits and
you know several organizations say that
just doesn't happen for Palestinians
Arabs should not come and cry why our
house is being demolished when they
choose to build illegally but they
choose not to build with a permission
because because they save time they save
money and they don't pay tax it's not as
if Palestinian families want to go and
build illegally or unlawfully according
to Israeli law it's that there is a near
complete inability to obtain these these
building permits the rate of approval is
very very low compared to what is being
built and what is being approved for
Jewish Israelis you can see just the
Stark the Stark disparity between
that so just to give you an idea of
where everything is up there is the old
City this entire area is a Palestinian
neighborhood of silwan you can see just
how close everything is over on this
side are several ongoing eviction cases
and then down here this entire section
is subject to an Israeli demolition
plan it's called al-bustan and the
Jerusalem municipality wants to
redevelop the area and create a Biblical
themed Garden that would link up to
other religious and archae ological
sites nearby there are more than a 100
houses here and most of them are
considered illegal because they don't
have the right permits even though
Palestinians own the land like nidal Al
rajabi who's got a demolition order on
his house he sees the garden plan and
all the technicalities around building
permits as a pretext for something
[Music]
bigger
fore
so across East Jerusalem Palestinians
are fighting to hold on to their homes
and neighborhoods at the same time
there's more money and more land being
allocated for Israeli Jews to settle
here 12 Israeli settlements have been
built in East Jerusalem since
1967 over the years they've expanded and
become established residential areas
with lots of amenities like parks and
schools it's been a while since any new
Israeli settlements were built but
that's now
changing we are along the southern
perimeter of East
Jerusalem what we're seeing right now
we're seeing a lot of the construction
of the foundation and infrastructure on
the area in Gat Matos Gatos is slated to
be the first new settlement in East
Jerusalem to be built in the past 20
years we're talking about thousands of
housing units that are designated for
Jewish Israelis um even though it is is
surrounded by Palestinian
neighborhoods you actually have
basically a spotting a series of
different settlement plans that are
along the southern perimeter you see if
you kind of connect the dots how it
creates this entire wedge of Israeli
settlement building you cut off East
Jerusalem from the southern West Bank
there is then no territorial contiguity
necessary for a viable Palestinian state
with a capital in in East Jerusalem that
idea is Central to the so-called
two-state solution that was agreed 30
years ago as the basis for Peace So a
Palestinian State alongside Israel with
East and West Jerusalem becoming their
respective
capitals global leaders still cling to
the idea but in practice any kind of
peace process has been dead for
years and what's happening in East
Jerusalem helps to confirm that so
what's written
here
[Music]